Carrie I'm I love entrepreneurship
dearly I love entrepreneurship one
because like you said it's job creating
uh and and
um but also it's self-actualizing it's a
if you tell someone look you have to go
build it you have to solve a problem you
care about that's just a very different
process and a different set of uh people
that result then hey your goal is to get
this badge and then if you get that
badge then you'll get in you'll get into
this org and then they'll reward you a
lot and then you know it's it's just a
different mindset I spent six and a half
years uh training young entrepreneurs
I'm still involved with a number of
startups today
um and so I I love the fact that you
also were a part of cultivating that in
the Next Generation and like you said
it's not necessarily that you're gonna
go out and start a company uh you know I
mean you can join a firm in various ways
I did write a book on this subject uh
called smart people should build things
about entrepreneurship
um uh back in my adventure for America
days
um I don't know if you'd ever you
probably wouldn't have I mean there are
a lot of Entrepreneurship books out
there but but that that was about my
time training entrepreneurs no but I'm
going to read it now I'm clearly going
to go go get it now so I I think that
one of the most interesting things about
you know watching these kids build
things is that they are so proud of
their efforts and and so invested and
when we talk about young people today
and and many of the you know the the
challenges facing them so often they
feel out of control they feel depressed
they feel that you know they feel not
optimistic about the world around them
and in so many ways entrepreneurship and
really just the the entrepreneurial
mindset you don't have to be starting a
company but but having that mindset that
I have control of my life I'm going to
do things that are going to make the
world a better place I'm going to gather
with a few friends and make the changes
that I can make that can really I I
didn't see the same uh issues that that
I see in in young people in America in
general so much at Babson because they
were empowered they they really felt
that they could make a change they could
they could do something with their lives
and and that they weren't just subject
to all of these really huge Trends
whether it's you know climate change or
whether it's just the country Ai and
automation political climate AI all of
these things that just feel overwhelming
to people right now
um the idea that you can be engaged in
something that is going to try to at
least control your world and maybe have
an impact on the broader world is a is a
very comforting and and empowering
feeling for young people you know what I
find to be the antidote for anxiety and
depression uh is action and agency uh
it's this locus of control is what we
used to call it at Venture for America
but it's look like you control
your own certainly your own State of
Mind well you know you can't totally
control that but you can influence that
all your behavior you can take action
one of the reasons why I enjoy what
we're doing with forward so much is I
only feel better about a problem if I'm
doing something about it and if you
don't do anything about it then the
problem can really really plague you
that's right and and I think that
entrepreneurship also teaches you to
take reasonable risks right people often
think of entrepreneurs as big Risk
Takers and but they aren't they they try
to measure like what's a risk I can
afford to take and and invest in that
but by that incremental risk taking you
really become more Brave and more wise
about what what the risk really entails
and that's a lot of the concerns that
people have today are around this notion
that they they can't take risks because
the the outside forces are so strong and
when starting starting a new party right
it's a big risk and a lot of people say
to me oh what you know like what are you
thinking it's not it's going to take 20
years you have to start somewhere and
you have to take a risk it's not that
big of a risk it's a bigger doing
nothing I hope forward becomes the party
of entrepreneurs and Entrepreneurship
and building an agency and giving us
back control of our own Futures but I I
couldn't agree more with the the
sentiment you just expressed that most
of the risks people are talking about
are Phantom risks
I think that drives me nuts that there
are so many people that's like oh can't
do this can't do that it's like wait a
minute there's a bigger risk of us
sitting around and waiting for uh the
bad things to overtake us uh you're you
know that's that's or when I was young
and I started my first company that
totally flopped by the way
um I thought that the risk was looking
in the mirror 30 years later and not
having done anything
um which by the way you know I was like
well that's a risk I could control like
I could uh you know I can at least take
a few shots at something
um and when I was recruiting for Venture
for America I told my wife this story
the other day and she thought it was
really funny what I said to a bunch of
22 year olds I said look things might
not always work out for you if you head
down this entrepreneurial path but at
least you'll be able to remember what
year it was like at least you'll be able
to remember what the heck you were doing
and that gave Evelyn a real laugh but
it's to me really I think people tend to
very much overweight certain risks to
your point and then underweight others
when I was working at the center for
advancing the American dream I got to
meet a lot of entrepreneurs who had come
here from other countries and had had
specifically chosen to start their their
firms and their Ventures here in the U.S
even though they were from Europe or
Russia or Africa or South South America
where you know all over the world but
they they felt that the environment here
was more conducive to success and and
starting new Ventures and part of that
was that we believe in forgiveness and
new starts you know New Beginnings for
people so failure isn't this permanent
State of Affairs like you know that's
the guy who started a business once oh
well you know it failed and he's a
failure forever it's more like you can
be proud of the fact that you tried to
do something whether it failed or
succeeded you can be proud of it I'm
proud of running for office for however
many times I did and I failed way more
times than I succeeded so I you know I
think that we in America have you know
we take it for granted that we have this
notion of allowing people to begin again
and and have infinite numbers of of
lives and and careers and expressions
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you